widely shared emotional Facebook videos
starting a whole new national
conversation about bullying
his name is Keaton Jones he's a middle
school student from East Tennessee he
described his experience of being
taunted during school lunches this video
taken and posted by his mother has been
viewed more than 20 million times a
University of Tennessee quarterback saw
the video and tweeted this picture on
Sunday evening after spending time with
Keaton he wrote this we have a lot in
common why did that boy what what's the
point of it in this video Keaton Jones
opens up to his mom about his bad dog
school what did I say to you the 11 year
old said fellow students poured milk on
him and stuff food in his clothes how's
that make you feel his pain has been
felt by millions hate Keaton his Delanie
Walker Tide and for the Tennessee Titans
including athletes and celebrities go
check him out his name's Keaton what
makes you so special is that there is
only one you this really has a lasting
impact on children CBS News contributor
psychologist Lisa d'amour says one of
the keys to squashing bullying behavior
is adult supervision when there is
better supervision at launch and in
locker rooms and in passing periods we
see bullying rates go down in the end
Keaton Jones offered tearful advice to
other victims of bullying
probably get better wouldn't they well
it's gotta get better one day we were
unable to reach Keaton's middle school
for comment about this a go fund me page
meant to bankroll his education more
than doubled its twenty thousand dollar
goal in just one day and the thing I'm
so happy about is that his mom posts
video so many times parents say to boys
in particular don't cry it'll be okay
suck it up I'm so glad that she posted
this video to show this stuff is wrong
it's wrong he's a he's clearly a brave
little boy for speaking up and showing
that much vulnerability and and she kept
asking and how does it make you feel
because everyone needs to know the
effect of their actions and how damaging
they are how damaging this abuse is so
now the question is what are other
parents doing with other that's right or
maybe they're in that system or made a
good point it starts with the parents